moments ago the house passed a
bipartisan resolution demanding the
immediate resignations of the MIT
president Sally cornbluth and haror
president Claudine gay now leaving aside
the fact that maybe Congressional
involvement in the hiring and firing of
University heads would set a wild
precedent these institutions they don't
care about accountability we know that
their credibility is now in the toilet
especially Harvard's not only is the
board standing behind claudi and gay the
university went to extreme lengths to
cover up any investigation the New York
Post reports that back in October they
asked Harvard about more than two dozen
instances of perceived plagiarism from
claudian gay two days later the post
says lawyers tried to silence them so
Harvard will go to bat from his gay but
not for the students who pay nearly
$55,000 a year to go there like the7
seven who were forced to withdraw from
the school due to academic dishonesty in
the 2021 school year so does the honor
code only apply to them and not to
certain School leaders of a preferred
background joining me now is Dr Peter
wood he's a former Boston University
associate Provost who's investigated
numerous plagiarism accusations and he's
currently president of the National
Association of
Scholars now Dr Wood um
I've read all of the passages in
question and to me this seems clearcut
that she lifted the exact language or
maybe slightly tweaked languages words
here or there from other authors and
Scholars without the proper attribution
or am I missing something you're not
missing anything at all in most cases it
wasn't without the proper attribution it
was without any attribution she
pretended that those words and sentences
were her own and but those uh thoughts
were Heron this was a a case of um
attempting to take credit for somebody
else's work now um plagiarism is not
something that the American public has I
think a really good intuitive grasp of
there's a tendency to think that if the
person who got plagiarized is okay with
it then there's no problem but the
problem is that plagiarism is a an
offense against the whole community of
Scholars which depend on the trust and
honesty of Scholars to put their own
ideas down on paper it doesn't matter if
the other person go comes along
afterwards and says hey you're my buddy
that's okay or or they don't want to
offend Harvard I mean Harvard has an
enormous amount of power so these
Scholars who were plagiarized from they
don't want to get in on Harvard's Grill
because they probably want to you know
have their own deal with Harvard at some
point now um one example of her uh
writing um that was highlighted by the
campus newspaper shows that nearly every
word in one paragraph written by her in
'97 was apparently lifted from a paper
written the year before um again this is
clearcut this is not a question so I'm
going to say why does she get to skate
this may seem like an obvious question
Dr Wood but I'm going to ask you why
does Claudine gay get to skate on
obvious plagiarism she gets to skate
because her board is too embarrassed to
admit they may a terrible mistake in
appointing her she gets to skate because
there is behind this a ferocious
political movement she is the wokest
college President in the country and is
trying to lead a total transformation of
Harvard to allow her academic dishonesty
to get in the way of trying to U turn
Harvard into the U wedge that will
undo white supremacy or uh the systemic
racism that she sees around every corner
would upset the political commitments of
powerful people at Harvard well it
exposes it
exposes the truth about diversity Equity
inclusion that sadly it lowers standards
and it it actually hurts everybody it
doesn't help doesn't help people it
actually hurts people and she was the
first black president of Harvard black
black female president of Harvard and to
you know a few months into the deal say
whoops we made a mistake
I mean if she were let's just if she
were a white male kind of middle of the
road more milk toast
guy right would would he have lasted Dr
Wood um well someone with her record
would never have been appointed in the
first place except for the fact that
she's black and she is ultra woke but um
anybody else would be long gone as the
president of uh uh University of
Pennsylvania fell because of uh not
plagiarism but because of what she said
before the house um but gay is protected
right now but I think it's only for
right now the the cases of plagiarism
that Harvard is trying to cover up or
pretend are not that big a deal are the
tip of the iceberg now that Harvard has
taken this stand uh the people I work
with are examining her other work which
I fully expect is going to be revealed
as full of even more plagiarism um one
thing I know as someone who's dealt with
plagiarism cases for many years is that
most plagiarists are serial offenders
they get into the Habit they get away
with it so they keep on doing it and I
think we are about to see that Claudine
Gay's U tissue paper thin excuse for
this that it's just a error of
punctuation or something like that is
about to fall apart and well Nicole
Nicole Hannah Jones from the 1619
project
um says it's all racist all this all
this criticism that people like you are
raising is based in racism and you say
very
quickly uh the accusation of racism is
the last Refuge of Scoundrels as uh a
famous man once wrote um we are um in a
world here where people commit egregious
wrongs and try to get away with it by
saying don't blame me this is a matter
of only the racists are accusing me
well Peter um it's good to see you thank
you for joining us this is serious
business and we want Harvard and all
these institutions to actually be
credible it's better if we have credible
institutions Elite institutions this is
embarrassment for everyone hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else